you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is video 7
from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos and we're going to have a look
at how to give checkmate with the king
and rook versus the enemy king if you've
been following this channel or have been
connected in some way with this chest
network channel you know that I've
covered this video or at least there's a
good chance you'll know I've covered
this video before but I wanted to redo
this video specific for for a couple of
reasons specific for this playlist I
want to do this video and also because I
want to show you a more efficient
approach to solving this endgame ok so
if you've been following along in this
playlist here this beginner to chess
master playlist you know the first video
I covered was king and queen versus the
enemy king well things are quite similar
here in this endgame we will need to
force the enemy king to the edge of the
board in order to give checkmate so a
good place to start is to pick an edge
of the board we would like to force the
King to and force them there and then
finally give checkmate we will need to
be working as a team here you're using
them both our king and rook to force
checkmate against the enemy king to
force the king to the edge of the board
and then give checkmate and in this
example I'm going to force the enemy
came to this eighth rank with white
being on move here a good place to start
or a good move to start with is rook h3
cutting the king of not allowing him to
move away from this 8th rank after a
move here we get our King involved now
and after black moves you'll notice that
the visit the position of the Kings are
such that they're a knight's move away
from one another in this this is just
your visual cue when the Kings are
Knights move away from one another and
you're on move that's where you're going
to look to make a waiting move with your
rook and he still wants to perform the
same function of patrolling this third
rank so he's going to make a move
somewhere to this third rank more
specifically he's going to move to a
square where he's closer to our King
than our opponent's king
that might seem a little bit odd to view
it like that but I'll explain the move
here a good move would be rook to a3
making a waiting move it's kind of like
a passing move we essentially want the
enemy king to make another move you'll
notice if he's going here and lining
himself up with our King this is where
we will now look to give a check and
he's forced in the direction we want him
to go to okay in this example however
he's going to run away why exactly do we
make this waiting move to a3 why do we
want to position our rook such that he's
closer to our King than our opponent's
King well notice if we make a waiting
move like rook g3 we run into this this
move here it's a bit of a bug the King
is allowed to now attack our rook and we
have to move our rook again but if we
move up if we make the waiting move like
this rook a3 if he's ever moving in the
direction to one-day attack I rope he
will have to have lined himself up with
our King and then we're able to push him
around were able to push him back in the
direction we want him to go to but in
this example he runs away and our King
is the one who runs after him eventually
he has to line himself up with our King
when he's on the edge here he has to go
to one of these three and regardless of
which three he goes to we're able to
give a check here and we're slowly
making progress again slowly making
progress this is not the most efficient
approach this endgame I just want to
show you a one method here one that
highlights waiting moves in fact and
once again a position where it's a
knight's move away we're going to look
to make a waiting move in this case rook
h4 satisfies that condition of being
closer to our king than our opponent's
king and we run after him eventually
he's going to have to line himself up
and it's the same thing over and over
now how would we do this in a more
efficient way if this was to continue
the king would be running like this and
this going to this is going to take a
long long time how could we do it where
it is much more efficient if I was to
continue with this same method look at
how many moves this is taking it's
taking a real lot and it shouldn't take
this long here this would be an example
of a good waiting move in that position
and then finally that's a way we could
end 32 moves if you see on the right
hand side is a long well that's too long
you could do a in a better there's a
better approach so let's see what this
better approaches similar we're going to
still make waiting moves like this but
if this King is a little close to the
edge of the board like this he's on g4 4
or 4 chasing after him he's going
directly on an edge of the board who's
to say that we have to checkmate them
here we could always change our mind and
go what right here and say you know what
I'm going to checkmate you on this
h-file and notice how much more quickly
this is going to end
instead of taking 32 moves we're done in
just about a dozen moves here ok so the
main point here just as a quick recap is
to use both our king and rook it takes a
team effort in order to force the King
to the edge we want to look to cut the
King off when the Kings are Knights move
away from one another this will be our
visual cue to make that waiting move and
if he's close to the edge of the board
even here he doesn't have to be directly
on the edge what we could do is cut him
off right here and simply work with
these last two files look to cut him off
on this G file and then finally when
he's on the H file deliver checkmate
like this waiting move is called for
there we run after him a little bit we
could even cut them off like this and
then work over like this and then
finally give checkmate so there's no one
correct way there's going to be many
different ways you could do it I just
wanted to highlight this idea of cutting
the King off making waiting moves
there's a slow approach but I'll saw
this more efficient approach if the King
is towards the it near an edge of the
board feel free to shift gears you don't
have to be locked in to forcing the King
to one particular edge of the board you
could you could change it up along the
way depending on what you the enemy king
is doing ok so that's all for this video
as always I hope you got something out
of it and I'll catch you in video 8 take
care bye
you